LEWANDOWSKI, AND BRIAN KILMEADE.
THERE IS A CLEAR DOUBLE STANDARD
BETWEEN THE LEFT AND THE RIGHT.
BEHAVIOR THAT YOU ONLY SEE ON
THE LEFT AND NOT THE RIGHT.
IF YOU NEED FURTHER PROOF THAT
THERE IS A DOUBLE STANDARD, THAT
THE LEFT HAS GRAIN WASHED
SOCIETY, LOOK NO FURTHER THAN
FLORIDA.
THE FRAUD GOING ON IN FLORIDA AS
AN ACCEPTABLE SOLUTION TO OUR
ELECTION PROCESS IS THE LAST
STRAW.
HOW ARE THE SAME TWO COUNTIES WE
HAVE REPEATEDLY HAD TROUBLE WITH
IN THE PAST ARE ABLE TO SAY
THEIR ELECTION IS NOT FINAL.
HOW IS THAT POSSIBLE?
HOW IS THAT TRUE?
FLORIDA'S SECRETARY OF STATE HAS
OFFICIALLY DECLARED A RECOUNT.
REPUBLICAN RICK SCOTT WAS
DECLARED THE WINNER OVER
DEMOCRAT BILL NELSON.
REPUBLICAN RON DEAND FIST WAS
DECLARED WIN -- RON DESANTIS WAS
DECLARED THE WINNER OVER DEM
KRAMENT ANDREW GILLUM.
AND GILLUM WHO CONCEDED ON
ELECTION NIGHT JUST TODAY
OFFICIALLY PULLED BACK HIS
CONCESSION.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE REFUSING TO
ACCEPT THE RESULTS OF THE
NATIONAL MEDIA.
IN THE WORDS OF DNC LAWYER MIKE
ELIAS, CHRISTOPHER STEELE FRAUD
THRENTS DOSSIER INTENDED OLD FO
TO DISENFRANCHISE US ON THE
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
WE'LL DO A RECOUNT AND WE'LL
WIN.
HOW DO THEY DO THIS?
NECESSITY FIND MISSING BALLOTS.
WHERE DO THEY FINDS THEM?
IN DEEP BLUE COUNTIES RUN BY
DEMOCRATS IN FLORIDA, BROWARD
AND PALM BEACH.
BROWARD AND PALM BEACH COUNTIES
MAY SOUNDS FAMILIAR TO YOU.
IN 2000 THERE WAS A HAND RECOUNT
IN BROWARD COUNTY BECAUSE THE
DEMOCRATS DIDN'T WANT TO ACCEPT
THE RESULTS OF A PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION.
IN 2006 THERE WAS ANOTHER
RECOUNTS STARTED BY THE
DEMOCRATS.
IN 2016 ANOTHER RECOUNT AND 2018
ANOTHER RECOUNT IN THE SAME TWO
COUNTIES.
FOLKS, THERE 3,141 COUNTIES IN
THE UNITED STATES.
SO YOU TELL ME HOW 3,139
COUNTIES CAN GET THEIR VOTES IN
30 MINUTES AFTER THE POLLS
CLOSE, BUT NOT THESE TWO.
THE OTHER COUNTIES GET IT RIGHT.
THERE IS EVEN A COUNTY THAT
SUFFERED A CATEGORY 4 HURRICANE
IN FLORIDA THAT WAS ABLE TO TURN
IN THEIR BALLOTS 30 MINUTES
AFTER THE ELECTION.
BUT THE SAME TWO DEEP BLUE
DEMOCRAT CONTROLLED COUNTIES IN
FLORIDA WHERE THE REPUBLICANS
WON IN THE TWO MOST OF IMPORTANT
RACES CAN'T GET THEIR ACT
TOGETHER.
BUT IT'S NOT THE FIRST TIME.
THERE IS ONE PERSON WHO SEEMS TO
BE AT THE CENTER OF THIS.
MISS BRENDA SNIPES.
THE ELECTION SUPERVISOR IN
BROWARD COUNTY.
YOU MAY KNOW ABOUT BRENDA
BECAUSE IN 2016 A JUDGE CALLED
HER OUT FOR DESTROYING BALLOTS
THAT BENEFITED HER FRIEND DEBBIE
WASSERMAN-SCHULTZ.
SO ELECTION NIGHT BROWARD
REPORTS THOUSANDS OF VOTES, AND
NOW THERE ARE REPORTEDLY
THOUSANDS MORE VOTES.
YOU ARE KIDDING, RIGHT?
A PRIMER.
EVERY COUNTY IS SUPPOSED TO HAND
IN ALL EARLY VOTING AND ABSENTEE
BALANCE LOTS WITHIN 30 MINUTES
OF THE POLLS CLOSING.
MOST OF KANSAS CITY ALREADY
COUNT THOSE BALLOTS BEFORE
ELECTION NIGHT.
BUT NOW IN A LAWSUIT BROUGHT
AGAINST MISS SNIPES, GOVERNOR
SCOTT ARGUES MISS SNIPES IS
REFUSING TO COOPERATE.
THE COURT ORDERED MISS SNIPES TO
TURN OVER RECORD DETAILING HOW
SHE COUNTS BALLOTS.
SNIPES IS REFUSING TO TURN OVER
THE RECORD, SAYING IT'S
INAPPROPRIATE FOR A COURT INTO
THE SCREEN THIS TIME SIMPLY
BECAUSE SCOTT WANTS THE COUNTING
PROCESS SPED UP.
WHAT IS EVEN MORE OUTRAGEOUS IS
AFTER SNIPES DESTROYED BALLOTS
ILLEGALLY IN THE 2016 ELECTION.
HER PREMATURE DESTRUCTION OF THE
BALLOTS IN A PENDING LAWSUIT WAS
DESCRIBED AS UNLAWFUL AND IN
VIOLATION OF THE PUBLIC RECORDS
ACT.
THAT COURT IN 2016 CITED A
SIMILAR CASE WHERE THE
INDIVIDUAL WAS DISMISSED, SAYING
DISMISSAL UNDER THESE
CIRCUMSTANCES IS AN APPROPRIATE
SANCTION.
BUT THE COURT WENT EVEN BEYOND
SAYING THAT ABOUT SNIPES.
THEY SAID HER VIOLATION WAS
TWOFOLD.
NUMBER ONE, SNIPES VIOLATED
STATE AND FEDERAL RETENTION
REQUIREMENTS, AND NUMBER TWO,
SNIPES VIOLATED THE AFFIRMATIVE
RESPONSIBILITY TO PRESERVE
EVIDENCE.
WHY WAS THIS ROLL AND NOT FIRED?
YET TODAY MISS SNIPES WAS ON TO
MESS UP YET ANOTHER, OR OVERTURN
YET ANOTHER ELECTION IN FLORIDA.
IF THAT'S NOT ENOUGH TO
INFURIATE YOU AFTER THE COURT'S
DECISION ABOUT MISS SNIPES, THE
STATE OF FLORIDA ANNOUNCED IT
WOULD BE MONITORING BROWARD'S
2018 ELECTION.
LET ME TELL YOU WHAT A MESS WE
ARE IN.
THERE ARE REPORTEDLY THOUSANDS
OF NEWFOUND BALLOTS.
EACH ONE IS FIVE' PAGES LONG.
DO YOU THINK A WOMAN WHO LOSES
THOUSANDS OF BALLOTS, WHO
DOESN'T WANT TO TURN THEM IN
WITHIN 30 MINUTES OFF THE POLLS
ARE CLOSED SHOULD BE TRUSTED?
DO YOU THINK SHE SHOULD BE
ALLOWED TO VIEW FIVE TIMES,
BECAUSE THAT'S HOW LONG THE
BALLOTS ARE.
OF THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF
MISSING BALLOTS?
THIS IS LUNACY.
VOTER FRAUD IS INSIDIOUS.
IT CAUSES PEOPLE TO THINK THEIR
VOTE DOESN'T MATTER.
BUT IT'S WORSE THAN THAT, FOLKS.
THERE ARE REPORTEDLY TRANSCRIPTS
NOW THAT PROVE WHEN THE
DEMOCRATS SAY THEY WANT EVERY
VOTE COUNTED WHEN MIGHT.
BUT IT'S NOT JUST YOUR VOTE IT'S
ILLEGAL VOTES THAT SOME LAWYERS
IN THESE CANVASSING HEARINGS FOR
DEMOCRATS WANT COUNTED A REPORT
OUT TODAY SAYS LAWYERS FOR
DEMOCRATS GILLUM AND NELSON ARE
OBJECTING TO THE REJECTION OF
VOTES CAST BY NON-CITIZENS.
SO WHEN A LAWYER FOR DEMOCRATS
SAYS HE'S GOING DOWN TO FLORIDA
TO WIN, HE SHOULD HAVE ADDED, BY
ANY MEANS.
THAT'S MY OPEN.
IF YOU LOVE MY OPENING